[Applause]
what a wonderful holiday st. Patrick's
Day huh
I just gotta tell you I had a wonderful
st. Patrick's Day it was a little weird
not a lot of people in the bars today
but uh and I couldn't really get anyone
to kind of imbibe but oh I'll give to
the gap you know talk to me so much but
uh it's tomorrow tomorrow
now let's uh sure yeah I'm pretty sure
yeah yeah technically now but really
tomorrow is when they go to the one yeah
I made a gross miscalculation well let's
talk about I gotta say I have this
matter though know it well I've seen
people where my and I've seen people
where every kind of Yonsei if I could
say I have never seen I'm trying to put
the SEC's back in the st. Patrick's Day
oh yeah you know usually when a sexy
guest comes up I try to be cool about it
but I can't help but keep looking
[Applause]
what are you talking about playing the
sax back in the st. Patrick's Day I
don't know if you've ever been to
Ireland for st. passaic yeah that's a
very it's sexy there
I mean st. Patrick he's just saying to
getting it all it's completely a
different different like for instance do
you know our our perception of
traditional Irish music Yiddish is is in
fact could you guys give us a little
sample I know the traditional that's not
in Ireland if you go to Ireland I'll -
can you play some real Irish music
[Applause]
sit down sexy I have to boil this now so
that's what you call driving out the
snakes yeah
the Irish naughty that's the stupidest
thing anyone's ever done here since we
yelled at a duck not ten minutes ago
yeah where did you do with those dogs
yeah I don't know boo they're horrid
creatures back there horrid would you
let me ask you something where did you
where did you learn what did you learn
about st. Patrick's Day thank you
[Applause]
where did you get your perception of st.
Patrick's Day where does it come from
Farrell is an Irish last name I thought
subs are all from Ireland and in fact
and they must be proud they're very
proud in fact I brought some of my
cousins are in New York for st.
Patrick's Day and they came by the
studio and I'd love to bring them out
you're Irish
shake that Sheamus on the left haha :
captain the motor the male and there's a
Aiden right oh hey guys happy st.
Patrick's Day huh
[Applause]
what are you doing this is all I'm
working out clean-shaven
all the hair clippings you're here
before you're killing me
stop touching yourself please I will
give you my watch now sir not live
what's change this job sir not live are
you or not are you working on it I'm
gonna try really hard to have a serious
conversation with you are you are you
working on any new characters will
anything we can look forward to on the
show I'm working on one new character
yeah
which actually is it I worked on a movie
four years ago that with very special
film STV straight-to-video and so you
probably have never heard of it but the
one guy that I worked with one of the we
were three friends he overacted his
parts a little bit so this is a Jim
Ferguson the over actor okay so if you
could give me a line like you know hey
Jim you were supposed to be here at 3:00
let's just do a scene and I'll show you
my new character for good you ready yeah
I'm ready
well hey Jim you're supposed to be here
at 3:00 are you sure Conan I could have
sworn you told me for he gave it that
much on everything that much on
everything and was he dressed like this
now no one dresses like this all right
you have a I'm told that in addition to
this I mean this should be a treat but I
was told you how to treat for us tonight
a special thing I'm gonna do for tonight
which is this is all fun and games and
everything but yeah something serious
something serious
my father's musician actually music is a
big part of my life I've played the
drums since I was in the seventh grade
and always kept up with it but one of
the things that's going on in public
schools right now is the funding for
music programs is being basically
eliminated and a lot of these kids
that's a it's a big place a big problem
and a lot of kids aren't getting to
learn these type of things so and if I
hadn't had that I so I kind of visit
schools and try to help kids and see to
try keep this alive it's kind of my my
one crusade
I came apart I came across my friend
Remo here who's an excellent drummer
what is uh remo we're green okay he's a
drummer he's and you met a man years old
ten years old and we met at his school
up in the Bronx and I visited there oh
we're gonna have an old-fashioned drum
off and this is your way of you know
raising awareness of you know the plight
of funding for these music program okay
wow this is a nice idea you want to get
us started here let's take it away okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I think they get the idea you will
not get public funding now I'm in show
business I will trust you just take it
easy
you don't pull that stuff with me take
it easy all right Remo your ass is grass
everybody
[Applause]